President Trump just posted a new tweet
saying this the Democrats have said some
of the worst things about James Comey
including the fact that he should be
fired but now they play so sad CBS News
chief Washington correspondent Face the
Nation moderator John Dickerson joins us
from Washington so John what can you
tell us about what you're hearing in
Washington in your response to the
president's tweet today well you know
the tweet is the president seeing this
through political political lens and
there will be a lot of back-and-forth
between Democrats and Republicans on
this but the important thing to focus on
here about this decision is that it
takes place in a much bigger context
there are people working at the FBI
people at the Department of Justice this
is a decision that's not just about
politics this is a decision that they
have to look at and say is the re are
the reasons being put forward and the
timing of this and the rushed way it was
done and the way it was handled why why
did all of that happen is it but for all
the reasons stated in the letter about
the commis dismissal or is there
something else happening here and that
sense of doubt and getting rid of that
doubt is crucial if the FBI is going to
go forward if this investigation is
going to continue within the FBI and
have any credibility so the
ramifications here the president's
making a political case but there are
real ramifications here inside the FBI
and related to a lot of work that goes
on inside the administration that are
now really all up in the air and there's
a sense of turmoil John whether this
focus more intensive focus focus focus
on the Russian investigation well yes of
course because that's still ongoing the
president remember has called the
investigation into whether the Russians
were involved in the election and at any
connection with the Trump campaign a
witch hunt
usually the posture of an administration
is we we look forward to the conclusion
of this investigation we're doing
everything we can to help the president
has said that the FBI investigation and
the two committees in Congress are
engaged in a witch hunt so that's the
context here but one other piece of
context that is that the White House is
saying the president took decisive
action remember what happened Monday
there was a conversation about why the
president took so long to fire his
National Security Advisor Mike Flynn 18
days after being informed that he lied
about his conversation with the Russian
ambassador so the question that ray
is does the president take decisive
action when it is in his interest or
does he delay things when it is in his
interest sending a clear signal about
how a president behaves matters not just
because we need to know whether the
president is telling the truth but it
sends a signal throughout the
administration to all his political
allies about what kind of a person the
president is thanks John
thanks for joining us